Each branch of science attempts unifying
theories. Physics, for example, has
thermodynamics to bring together mechanics
and heat. Einstein’s relativity added to
the
unification of ideas, underscoring how
fundamental quantities like matter and energy
are just two sides of the same coin. We now
have wave-particle duality and a common
framework for understanding special relativity
in
the context of quantum mechanics. Yet the
ultimate grand unified “theory of everything”
– a
theory of quantum gravity - remains elusive.
Biology, on the other hand, has its “grand
unifying theory”, thanks
to Darwin’s theory of evolution by natural
selection, published in 1859, combined with
the theory of
heredity pioneered by Mendel, published a
few years later.
It is the story of this theory of heredity
that this lecture concerns,
made up, as you shall see, of a series of
revolutionary ideas
pioneered by some of the greatest scientists
the world has ever
known. It is an exciting story because it
concerns the revolution in
our molecular understanding of the very nature
of life itself, and it
is a very exciting time to be telling this
story, because we are
entering a period when we do not only understand
the ultimate
influence of genetics on everything about
life, but we are
developing the power to intervene in our genetic
destiny. Now is
the time to understand how this has come about,
what it means,
and how we should move forward, not just as
scientists, but as a
society.
Darwin’s big idea was that the variation
amongst creatures in their
natural environment results in the struggle
for life in which only the
most suitably adapted are preserved.
Evolution basically means gradual change over
time and natural
selection provides a mechanism for evolution.
Some change will be
favoured – it will make the organism more
likely to survive in a
particular environment and reproduce, producing
progeny with the
same traits. So you see, ultimately one type
of creature can be
transformed into something completely different.
In illustrating his
theory of evolution by natural selection,
Darwin realized that all
species are connected – indeed they share
a common origin – he
thought of the concept of the tree of life.
Darwin’s tree
was a simple one, and we now know it to be
more complex , but nonetheless Darwin was
right. Simple life forms
evolved 4 billion years ago, and natural selection
has sent organisms
off in a myriad of different directions to
make the extraordinary
diversity we have around us today.
– over 9 million species! Darwin talked
passionately about the
“Grandeur”, in his view of life, with
its “endless forms most beautiful
and most wonderful”. Darwin’s theory of
natural selection works so
well as a unifying theory in biology that
Theodosius Dobzhansky was
prompted to write, around 100 years later,
that “Nothing in biology
makes sense, except in the light of evolution”
The
problem with Darwin’s great idea, though,
was that Darwin had
no robust mechanism to explain inheritance,
and this rendered his
logic incomplete – his unifying theory failed
in this respect. Darwin
knew, of course, that traits run in families,
otherwise natural
selection wouldn’t work at all, but he had
no decent mechanism to
explain HOW inheritance works, despite recognizing
the supreme
importance of heredity, of “modification
by descent” in his
hypothesis.
So what were the prevailing theories of heredity
in Darwin’s day?
Among the earliest known writings on the subject
of
heredity are those of Hippocrates in 400 BC.
He believed that reproductive material
came from all parts of an organism and hence
that
characters were directly handed down to the
progeny.
As evidence in support of this hypothesis
he referred to a
race of mankind called the Macrocephali. Immediately
after a child was born, the Macrocephali fashioned
its
head by hand to give it an elongated shape.
At a later
period, the elongated head would form naturally,
without
the necessity for moulding it after birth,
in much the
same way that baldness and blue eyes are inherited.
If
reproductive material came from all parts
of an organism,
then it would come from the moulded head.
50 years or so later Aristotle questioned
this view. He
couldn’t understand how certain characteristics
such as voice, nails and
hair could contribute to the reproductive
material, since they were
intangible, or concerned dead tissue. He also
observed that children
sometimes looked more like their grandparents
than their parents. He
was puzzled, too, about plants.
How could parts which may be absent at the
time of reproduction (eg
leaves) be inherited? And how could it be
that parents could each
contribute something from all their parts,
yet their progeny have only
one and not two of each part? Aristotle modified
Hippocrates’ theory
by postulating that the reproductive material
is made up of
substances that have been diverted from various
parts to the
reproductive path. This was a really important
idea. He went on to
argue, however, that the contributions to
the progeny from the two
parents were not the same, and held the contribution
of the father in
somewhat higher regard (no surprises there!),
contributing shape and
form to the embryo, as opposed to the mothers
contribution of “inner
material” (in other words, all the dull
stuff).
Many variations of these “transmission theories”
were
proposed over the subsequent centuries. The
only
theory of heredity that has perhaps rivaled
it is the so-
called preformation theory, which can be followed
back to Saint Augustine.
This theory held that, in the creation of
the first
woman, all following generations were pre-formed,
and the theory gave rise to the idea of the
homunculus in the sixteenth century, although
Nicolas
Hartsoeker, who drew this homunculus in 1695
was
definitely a “spermist” in his view of
heredity.
Transmission theories, however, dominated
during
Darwin’s time. Thus Darwin, writing
in 1868 about his theory of pangenesis, suggested
that
all the cells and tissues of an organism threw
off
minute granules, called gemmules, which circulated
through the organism, multiplied, and were
passed
down to the reproductive cells, which thus
contained a
multitude of components thrown off from each
individual part of the organism. He also thought
gemmules were capable of transmission in a
dormant
state to future generations.
So Darwin had a way of explaining the non-expression
of parental characteristics as well as the
direct
transmission of characteristics from parent
to
offspring that was so important for natural
selection
to work.
He felt that Pangenesis, which he described
as a
“provisional hypothesis” in this 1868
work brought
together, in his words “a multitude of facts
which are
at present left disconnected by any cause”.
His
theory was not however so very different from
that of
Hippocrates over 2000 years previously.
It is remarkable that the Hippocratic view
remained essentially unchallenged for 23
centuries. It is not as though no-one did
any
breeding experiments during this time, especially
in the 18th and 19th centuries, it is more
the case
that, although these experiments did not support
the classical view, they did not present any
alternative hypothesis.
Until Mendel.
It is noteworthy that, several decades before
Mendel
published his work, at least two other plant
breeders
made very similar observations to Mendel.
Knight,
working in England in 1799, crossed unpigmented
and pigmented edible peas together.
He was surprised to find only pigmented plants
the
following year (the first filial generation),
but that
these, on self-pollination, produced both
pigmented
and unpigmented plants in the following generation.
From this he deduced that there was a “stronger
tendency” to produce coloured than colourless
plants.
Goss, also working in England, in 1824, made
similar discoveries,
but took the analysis slightly further: He
pollinated green seeded peas from a yellow
seeded variety, found
all yellow seeded plants in the first filial
generation, then on selfing
these, got pods with all green, all yellow,
or a mixture of both
green and yellow seeded plants the following
year.
But then he went for a further generation,
and discovered that
while the green peas bred true, only giving
green progeny, the
yellow yielded a mixture – some pods all
yellow and some with
both green and yellow peas intermixed.
Their problem? They didn’t count the numbers
of the two kinds of
peas (or if they did count them, they failed
to see the significance
of the numbers), and in doing so they both
failed to discover the
hereditary mechanism which Mendel found.
Forty-two years later, in 1866, Mendel had
been
doing similar experiments to those of Knight
and
Goss. His thoroughness in
recording the minutiae of his data enabled
him, by
a stroke of genius, to detect the underlying
mechanism and so to put forward an entirely
new
hypothesis for heredity.
The “Grandeur” in Mendel’s work is easily
obscured by
seemingly obscure facts and figures about
pea breeding
schemes. But on the contrary, the devil is
absolutely in the
detail – the grandeur is revealed by the
seemingly
mundane.
Working with the pigmented and unpigmented
peas, just
like Knight, Mendel also noted only pigmented
plants in the
F1 generation, and that, on self-pollination,
these plants
yielded both pigmented and unpigmented varieties
in the
F2 generation.
But he counted the numbers of each kind, finding
705 pigmented plants and 224
unpigmented plants among 929 plants. He observed
that
these frequencies were close to ¾ and ¼
of the total.
He called the pigmented character – present
in all the
immediate progeny of the cross and ¾ of the
following
generation – dominant, and the unpigmented
trait
recessive. In other words, inheritance is
particulate, it
is not a case of blending parental characteristics,
like
mixing paint.
Mendel also worked on the yellow/green seed
colour
characteristic first explored by Goss, confirming
that
yellow is dominant to green and that both
kinds
appear in the second generation after crossing.
But
again, he counted his peas, and out of 8023
plants,
6022 were yellow and 2001 green, again a close
approximation to ¾:1/4, or 3:1.
Mendel confirmed Goss’s observation that
the green peas bred true,
but he went much further. He found that
of 519 yellow pods, 166 bred true whereas
353 did not, instead
giving yellow and green seeds in the same
3:1 ratio as in the
previous generation. Mendel figured that 166
true breeding : 353
impure breeding was a close fit with 1/3:2/3
of the total. In other
words the F2 ratio of 3 dominant to 1 recessive
was really a ratio of
1 pure-breeding dominant to 2 impure dominant
to 1 recessive
(which always breeds true).
He pursued these plants for several generations
and showed that
the pure-breeding types always remained pure-breeding
and the
impure-breeding ones gave the same 1:2:1 ratio
in each subsequent
generation. Mendel was very cautious about
his data, and went on
to repeat his experiments with a total of
7 different character
differences: one character was always dominant
to its alternative,
and the second generation always gave a 3:1
ratio, which on closer
inspection turned out to be a disguised 1:2:1
ratio.
What did all this mean? Mendel built a
hypothesis to account for his data in which
he used symbols for his
traits – “Y” for the dominant one and
“y” for the recessive character. It
is clear from this that he was thinking about
“factors” or
“determinants” responsible for the manifestation
of the character. This
is absolutely crucial: his characters were
not transmitted directly from
generation to generation according to the
classical theory, but rather
there are discrete particles responsible for
the appearance of
particular characters.
Furthermore, each individual receives one
particle from each of its
two parents in respect of a particular character,
and these two
particles separate uncontaminated when the
reproductive cells are
generated. So if Y denotes the particle that
determines yellow seeds,
and y green, then the parents YY and yy give
rise to offspring Yy (yellow
because this character is dominant). Self-pollination
of Yy will yield YY,
Yy, Yy and yy, ie 3 yellow to 1 green at the
phenotypic ratio, which is
really a disguised 1:2:1 ratio when you consider
the factors themselves.
A further point which didn’t escape Mendel’s
reasoning was that
egg cells carrying Y were as equally likely
to be fertilized by pollen
carrying Y or y. In other words, fertilization
was random between
egg cells and pollen cells (egg cells and
sperm cells for animals!),
regardless of what factors they carried. This
later became known as
his law of equal segregation.
Mendel was sitting on a revolution of incalculable
proportion, but
nobody noticed. He published his work in
1866, two years BEFORE Darwin published his
pangenesis theory of
blending inheritance based on his gemmules
made from all parts of
the organism. It seems extraordinary in these
days of instant
communication that Darwin never came into
contact with this work
– what would have happened if Darwin and
Mendel had met and
discussed Mendel’s results? Darwin would
surely have been
perplexed that Mendel’s F1 peas weren’t
yellowish green, and that
he didn’t observe blending characteristics,
but rather that the
mode of inheritance suggested by Mendel’s
work was most
definitely particulate. I wonder what he would
have said?
As it happened, Mendel’s work was almost
entirely
overlooked for 34 years, being rediscovered
in 1900
coincidentally by three different scientists,
De Vries, Correns and von Tschermak, working
on a
variety of different plant species. Correns
introduced the
term “Mendels Regel”, or “Mendel’s
Law) for the basic
principle, namely the segregation of the discrete
particulate determinants of alternative characters
when
reproductive cells (we would now call these
gametes) are
formed, and their re-association at fertilization.
De Vries is credited with introducing the
term “mutation”
to describe suddenly appearing variations,
which could
provide the raw material for natural selection.
Bateson and Saunders, working in 1902, were
the first to apply
Mendelian Law to an animal species, the domestic
fowl Gallus
domesticus, finding for example that an extra
toe was dominant to
the normal foot. Bateson and Saunders also
applied Mendelian
theory to earlier, unexplained data, and even
re-examined Darwin’s
1868 work on the snapdragon Antirrhinum majus.
One form of the snapdragon, the peloric form,
differs in having a
regular radially-symmetrical flower instead
of the normal irregular
two-lipped variety. Darwin interpreted the
results of his crosses as
indicating that the tendency to produce normal
flowers prevailed
in the F1 generation, but that “the tendency
to pelorism appeared
to gain strength by the intermission of a
generation”. With
Mendel’s theory it was only necessary to
postulate that the peloric
trait was recessive – it disappeared in
the F1 generation and re-
appeared in F2 in the 1:3 ratio.
Thus the classical and Mendelian theories
of heredity can be very
clearly teased apart: In the classical theory,
something is transmitted
directly from each part of the organism (eg
the snapdragon flower)
to the corresponding part in the progeny,
whereas in the Mendelian
world, inheritance is indirect through the
agency of particulate
determinants.
It is these determinants that are transmitted
from generation to
generation, and the character of the flowers
(or whatever) that
develop is simply the fortuitous combination
of the set of
determinants that it happens to receive at
fertilization.
The contributions of each parent retain their
integrity rather than
blending with the contribution of the other
parent. And crucially, the
determinant is not modified by its presence
in an organism. Thus the
inheritance of the remodeled head in the Hippocratic
example given
in support of the classical theory, is impossible.
The major problem in biology in the early
1900s, following
the re-discovery of Mendel’s work was that
its relevance to
evolution was unclear and hotly debated. Variation
in wild
populations looked continuous. – like
the product of blending inheritance, not the
discrete
model proposed by Mendel. And how could you
account
for large jumps and new species?
Crucial to solving this problem was the study
of
populations in the field (an area we would
now call
population genetics). RA Fisher was the major
figure in the
development of the so-called Modern Synthesis,
producing
in 1918 his seminal paper “The
correlation between relatives on the supposition
of
Mendelian inheritance”. Sounds really dull,
but it was very
far from that.
What Fisher did crucially in this paper was
show that
continuous variation could be the result of
the action of
many discrete determinants (we would now call
these
genetic loci) – therefore Mendelian genetics
was in fact
completely consistent with the idea of evolution
driven by
natural selection.
The application of Mendelian principles to
populations
was furthered in the 1920s, 30s and 40s by
Fisher along
with JBS Haldane (after whom this lecture
is named),
Sewall Wright, Dobzhansky, EB Ford, Ernst
Mayr and
others, but time does not allow me to give
due credit to
their crucial work on the maintenance of genetic
diversity,
genetic polymorphism and the mechanism by
which new
species become reproductively isolated.
This new work on population genetics is my
second
revolution in Genetics, following Mendel’s
great theory of
heredity in 1866 and its rediscovery in 1900.
This second
revolution resulted in the grand unifying
theory of
biology – the paradigm of evolution by natural
selection
with an integrated mechanism of heredity that
could be
applied to populations. Variation at the genetic
level, or
mutation, provides the raw material required
for natural
selection to sculpt evolution through many
generations.
The third revolution has to be the chromosomal
theory.
It’s all well and good talking about factors
and particles of
inheritance, but what are they, and where
are they? Well,
the “where” was answered by Thomas Hunt
Morgan at about the same time that the Modern
Synthesis was being developed. The “what”
had to wait a
few years.
Bizzarely, Thomas Hunt Morgan was born in
Kentucky in
1866, the same year that Mendel published
his work. By
the time that Morgan began his work on the
fruit fly
Drosophila in 1910, Mendel’s discoveries
were codified
into two main laws.
The first rule we have already come across,
the law of equal
segregation, The second rule was known as
the rule of free
combinations (we would now call this the law
of
independent assortment), and this states that
when new
generations arise, the different hereditary
factors can form
new combinations, independently of each other.
Mendel
found this out when he did his so-called dihybrid
crosses.
For example, if a tall, purple flowered plant
is crossed with a
short, white flowered variety, the factors
purple and white
can be inherited independently of the factors
tall and short
– you’ll end up with tall, white flowered
plants and so on, in
precisely predictable ratios.
Morgan’s particular genius was that he spotted
some
inconsistencies in this second law, and then
had the
confidence to seek an explanation for them.
Morgan found the first discrepancy when he
crossed flies
that had purple eyes and short wings with
those that had
red eyes and normal wings.
Now, under Mendel’s second law, he
expected to get
purple eyed flies with normal wings out of
his crossing
scheme at the same frequency as getting his
red eyed,
normal winged flies back again, because the
factors should
assort independently from one another, but
this was not
the case at all.
He got the purple eyed, normal winged flies
out only very
rarely. Morgan’s great leap forward was
to figure that the
eye colour trait and the wing size traits
must be physically
connected together in some way.
He called this phenomenom linkage, and found
that there
were many examples of this in his fly crosses,
but,
importantly, that the linkage relationships
were confined to
4 combination groups.
Now, in parallel to all this work with fly
crosses, the early
cell biologists were also busy in the late
19th and early 20th
centuries, and the importance of their work
was not lost on
Morgan. The mechanism of fertilization had
been
discovered by Hertwig in 1875 and
Weissmann took to the microscope in the 1880s,
having
distinguished between the hereditary material,
the germ
plasm (or germline, giving rise to the gametes),
and the
rest of the body, the soma, to propose that
the nucleus of
the male and female germ cells must be the
bearers of
hereditary qualities. Much earlier than this,
several
disciples of the new “cell biology” had
observed threadlike
structures in cells named chromosomes (meaning
“coloured body”) in 1888 by Heinrich von
Waldeyer-Hartz
.
But nobody knew what they were for.
On the rediscovery of Mendel’s work in the
early 1900s,
Sutton and Boveri independently suggested
that
chromosomes were good candidates for the exact
distribution of hereditary factors at the
genesis of a new
individual, simply because of the proportion
of the
chromosomes in germ cells before and after
fertilization –
in the chromosomes, factors could be combined
or could
come apart, because there were double the
number of
chromosomes in the somatic cells compared
with the sex
cells. The process of halving the
number of chromosomes during the generation
of the sex
cells, or gametes, is known as meiosis, a
reductional
division. Sutton and Boveri’s idea of chromosomes
distributing hereditary factors during the
formation of
gametes had huge resonance with Mendel’s
first law of
equal segregation.
So the ground was well prepared for Morgan
to link cell
biology to heredity – his linkage groups
of connected
hereditary factors turned out to be chromosomes,
and the
number of such combination groups, or linkage
groups, in an
organism, turned out to be the same as the
number of
chromosomes in an organism – 4 in the case
of the fruit fly,
23 in us.
Morgan’s discovery of linkage completed
proved, and greatly
extended, the chromosomal theory of inheritance
proposed
by Sutton and Boveri. Morgan’s linkage rule
limited to a large
extent Mendel’s second law as being more
applicable to
hereditary factors residing on different chromosomes.
Morgan published his chromosome map, with
different
hereditary factors lined up in chromosomes
like beads in a
necklace.
However, there was more. Morgan found inconsistency
in his
own linkage theory. He found that even when
his factors were
connected on the same chromosome, he could
still see some
degree of what looked like “independent
assortment”, even
though it was rare (remember the purple-eyed,
normal-
winged flies? – he did get some of them).
He called this
phenomenon “crossing over” and he envisaged
the physical
exchange of parts between chromosomes occurring
at the
cross-over points, or chiasmata.
This
theory of crossing-over was greeted by much
skepticism
at the time, until 1931 when Harriet Creighton
and Barbara
McClintock were able to visualize reciprocal
exchange of
genetic material at much higher resolution.
Nowadays, of
course, we call this process of genetic exchange
recombination, and it is an extremely important
mechanism
for generating genetic diversity during reproduction.
So the third revolution is the chromosomal
theory of inheritance –
linking Mendelian ideas of heredity into the
physical structure of
chromosomes, which behave so as to obey Mendel’s
first law, and
disobey his second where factors are linked
on the same chromosome.
Morgan’s work was utterly extraordinary.
Who would have thought it would be possible
to localize in these
chromosomes, which are only a micrometer or
so long (that’s one
thousandth of a mm), thousands of hereditary
factors, accounting for all
of the characters that makes every organism
what it is, and do it all by
analyzing the results of fruit fly crosses!
When Morgan got the Nobel
Prize in 1933, his work was likened to the
astronomical calculation of
celestial bodies still unseen but later on
found by the telescope, but
more so. It was said that Morgan’s predictions
exceed this by far,
because they mean something principally new,
something that has not
been observed before.
In Morgan’s own words “That the fundamental
aspects of
heredity should have turned out to be so extraordinarily
simple supports us in the hope that nature
may, after all, be
entirely approachable. Her much-advertised
inscrutability
has once more been found to be an illusion
due to our
ignorance. This is encouraging, for, if the
world in which we
live were as complicated as some of our friends
would have
us believe we might well despair that biology
could ever
become an exact science”.
The term “gene” was first coined in 1909
by Johanssen
to describe physical and functional units
of heredity, but the role of genes wasn’t
clarified until the
1940s in a landmark study by George Beadle
and Edward
Tatum that takes us to the start of our 4th
revolution, the
molecular biology revolution.
This major revolution actually consists of
several sub-
revolutions, some of which seem to get more
air-time than
others, but for simplicity, and in the interests
of time I have
lumped together about 40 years of work and
several of
these sub-revolutions and will now attempt
a whistle-stop
tour which takes us up to the 1980s.
Beadle and Tatum were working on the haploid
fungus
Neurospora. They irradiated Neurospora
cells to induce mutations and then tested
cultures for
interesting mutant phenotypes. They found
numerous
mutants that had defective nutrition, for
example in the
biosynthetic pathway by which arginine is
made in the cell.
They were able to block the pathway at different
steps with
different mutants, eventually figuring that
each gene
controlled one specific enzyme in a series
of interconnected
steps in a biochemical pathway – the one
gene-one enzyme
hypothesis. Beadle and Tatum’s hypothesis
was a significant
unifying concept, because it provided a bridge
that brought
together the two major research areas of genetics
and
biochemistry. So sub-revolution number 1:
one gene-one
enzyme (or protein).
What were genes made of? To answer this question
we need
to start with Frederick Griffith in 1928,
performing
experiments on the bacterium streptococcus
pneumonia.
Some strains of this bacterium are lethal
when injected into
mice while other non-virulent strains are
not.
Griffith made the puzzling observation that
if he injected the
non-virulent strain into mice together with
a heat-killed
virulent strain (which on its own would not
be lethal), the
mice died. Live bacterial cells could be recovered
from the
dead mice, which were virulent when injected
into live mice.
Somehow, the cell debris of the heat-killed
virulent cells had
converted the non-virulent live cells into
virulent ones – in
other words the cells had become transformed.
Now we fast forward to 1944 when Oswald Avery
working
with two colleagues MacLeod and McCarty, set
out to
chemically destroy all the major chemical
components of the
dead cells one by one, and test if the extract
had lost the
ability to transform. You can guess what they
found – DNA –
not polysaccharides or proteins or fats or
RNA – just DNA,
plain and simple. DNA is the transforming
principle and this
was the first demonstration that genes are
composed of DNA.
Sub-revolution number 2: DNA is the genetic
material
contained in genes which confer characteristics.
Between you and me, this was a bit of a let
down. How could such a
low-complexity molecule as DNA encode the
diversity of all life on the
planet? DNA was already known, you see, because
it was first isolated as
nuclein, by Meischer in 1869. Following Meischer’s
discovery of DNA, the Russian biochemist Levene
worked out that DNA
was a polynucleotide in 1919, by doing what
biochemists tend to do –
chopping things up (using hydrolysis in this
case), with each nucleotide
being composed of just one of four nucleotide
bases, a sugar molecule
and a phosphate group.
Sub-revolution number 3: DNA is composed of
four nucleotide bases, a
sugar molecule and a phosphate group. Levene
proposed what he
called a tetranucleotide structure, in which
nucleotides were always
linked in the same order G-C-T-A-G-C-T-A,
but scientists eventually realized that this
was oversimplistic, and that
the order of nucleotides is in fact highly
variable. Sub-revolution
number 4: the order of bases in a DNA molecule
is variable (perhaps it
acts as a code).
It was Chargaff, who worked out that the amount
of adenine (A) is usually similar to the amount
of
thymine (T), and the amount of guanine (G)
usually approximates the amount of cytosine
(C) . Chargaff was very inspired
by Avery’s 1944 paper. He wrote “Avery
gave us
the first text of a new language, or rather
he
showed us where to look for it. I resolved
to search
for this text.” Sub-revolution number 5:
A=T, C=G.
Chargaff’s work, together with some crucially
important X-
ray crystallography work by English researchers
Rosalind
Franklin and Maurice Wilkins,
paved the way for Watson and Crick’s derivation
of the
three-dimensional, double helical model for
the structure of
DNA in 1953.
In their Nature paper Watson and Crick began
“we wish to
suggest a structure for the salt of deoxyribonucleic
acid
(DNA). This structure has novel features,
which are of
considerable biological interest.” This
was no mean feat –
you could fit 25,000 strands of DNA, side
by side, in the
width of a single adult hair. And this is
sub-revolution
number 6, one of the biggies: DNA structure
.
One long molecule spiraling around in a double
helix. Equisite, simple, ordered and regular.
strands, each with a strong backbone made
of
sugar and phosphate, with the bases on the
inside, A pairing with T and C with G. Watson
and Crick’s discovery of the structure of
DNA is
considered by some to be the most important
biological discovery of the 20th century.
The
reason for this is that the double helix
structure fulfilled the three requirements
for a
hereditary substance:
Firstly - sequence. The 4 bases make up an
alphabet of four letters – a genetic code
to specify
the sequence of amino acids in proteins – known
to
be crucial for cellular functions. Fred Sanger
had
determined the first protein amino acid sequence
of insulin in 1951, so the amino acid sequence
was
begging for some kind of genetic code. Perhaps
the
genetic code could write information in DNA
as a
sequence of nucleotides and then translate
it into a
different language of amino acid sequences
in a
protein.
Secondly - if the base sequence of DNA specifies
the amino acid sequence in proteins, then
change,
or mutation, is possible by the substitution
of one
type of base for another at one or more positions
–
giving rise to altered proteins and likely
altered
cellular function. This is heavy stuff – mutation
would account for the genetic variation investigated
by Mendel, and the driving force of natural
selection in Darwinian evolution. No wonder
Francis Crick burst into the Eagle pub in
Cambridge
on Feb 28th 1953 and said “we have discovered
the
secret of life”
Thirdly - copying. As Watson and Crick stated
in the
concluding words of their paper “it has
not
escaped our notice that the specific pairing
we
have postulated immediately suggests a possible
copying mechanism for the genetic material”
. If you have pairing, and
free nucleotides in the cell, and enzymes,
then you
have DNA replication. And here’s an extraordinary
fact: everyday we each produce around 60 billion
new cells, replicating in excess of 100 billion
metres
of DNA in the process. That is the distance
to Mars
and back!
So DNA is a code, a code that holds all the
information to make all living things, an
instruction
manual to make a worm or a cat, or a fly or
a
human or a dinosaur. Its regularity, stability
and
predictability make it the perfect system
for storing
the vast amount of information necessary for
building life. The information is passed to
every cell
of an organism because perfect copies are
made
prior to each cell division, and one copy
of
everything is distributed to each reproductive
cell
or gamete in the germ line and thence passed
through the generations.
Sub-revolution number 7 is the cracking of
the
code. Convincing proof that a codon (a sequence
of
nucleotides that code for one amino acid)
is, in fact,
3 letters long, came from extremely elegant
experiments in 1961 by Francis Crick, Sydney
Brenner and co-workers using mutations in
viruses
that infect bacteria, called bacteriophage.
Essentially, they found that combinations
of three
nucleotide additions or three deletions were
okay,
suggesting a triplet code. The code was cracked
later that same year by Nirenberg, Matthaei
and
colleagues, so that individual amino acids
could be
associated with particular codons.
The next thing that exercised the molecular
biologists was the business of gene regulation,
sub-
revolution number 8. The
problem was that if DNA codes for proteins
that
give cells their particular characteristics,
and all the
cells of an organism of a particular species
contain
the same DNA sequence (because the DNA
sequence is of course the thing that defines
the
particular species), then how come cells can
do
different things at different times in different
parts
of the body and so on?
The breakthrough involved Jacques Monod, a
young Parisian molecular
biologist and Francois Jacob, a medical student
intent on becoming a
surgeon. After the invasion of France, Jacob
served as a medic in the
free French forces before he was badly wounded,
Monod joined the
resistance where he met another molecular
biologist Andre Lwoff. After
the liberation of Paris Monod served in the
French army, and happened
upon, in a mobile US army library, Avery’s
article suggesting that DNA is
the hereditary material (!).
With his interest in genetics rekindled, he
joined Lwoff after the war to
work on phage and bacteria, as did Jacob,
whose injuries were too
severe for him to pursue a career in surgery.
The cast of three was set . Over the next
decade one of the most
creative and productive collaborations in
the history of genetics worked
out how genes are turned on and off with a
toggle switch, how they
can make a protein, or not. Essentially, they
found that genes govern the
formation of proteins that can block the expression
of other genes by
binding to and acting on the DNA itself.
Their findings were deduced entirely from
genetic evidence,
from studying the effects of mutations. In
Horace Freeland
Judson’s wonderful book “The Eighth Day
of Creation”, which
describes the ferment of the whole molecular
biology
revolution, Jacob and Monod’s work is described
as making
“things that were utterly dark, very simple”.
The concept of
the genetic switch went far beyond bacterial
enzymes and
viruses. They understood, and were able to
articulate with
exceptional eloquence, how their discoveries
about gene
regulation pertained to the general mysteries
of cell
differentiation and embryonic development
in animals, where
the problem of the common set of genetic instructions
in
every cell is particularly acute. “what
is true for E. coli is also
true for the elephant”, quipped Monod.
And that brings us to the end of the molecular
biology
revolution, which culminated in a molecular
understanding
of the nature of the gene, including a copying
mechanism for
DNA through organisms and through generations
that meant
that heredity and the flow of genetic information
could
finally be understood in a much more tangible
way, involving
real molecules behaving in a way that is entirely
in keeping
with their structure. Thus the grand unifying
theory of
genetics and evolution could now be understood
at
molecular resolution.
What next? My 5th major revolution is forward
genetics –
using the genetic approach to understand not
just hereditary
mechanisms, but many other problems in biology.
It had been discovered by Muller in 1927 that
bombarding an organism (in his
case a fly) with X rays or treating it with
particular
chemicals could induce large numbers of inherited
mutations with clear effects on the morphology
–
the phenotype - of an organism. That of course
is
because the mutations cause a change in the
DNA
sequence, stopping the particular proteins
encoded by that DNA from working properly.
Biologists started to use the genetic approach
(ie the study
of mutants) to try to understand how genes
influenced other
hitherto mysterious bits of biology, one of
the most
important of these being development.
How does an organism develop from an egg to
an adult –
how does it end up the right size, with the
right number of
cells, all in the right place, doing the right
thing, at the right
time. It seemed like a problem of staggering
complexity, but
the problem could be reduced with the use
of model
organisms like Drosophila and others newer
on the scene like
the nematode worm C. elegans, introduced in
the 1970s.
You can see the power of this work by looking
at the
phenotypes of
some
of the mutants.
Although this approach had been used since
the 1920s it
took on a new vigour in the 1970s and 1980s,
firstly because
biologists now understood the nature of the
gene and could
map mutants using Morgan’s discovery of
linkage and the
chromosome theory, secondly because techniques
became
established for working out the sequence of
DNA, and
thirdly because it became possible to make
transgenic
animals.
That meant that the precise gene that had
gone wrong in
the mutant could be pinpointed, and also that
DNA could be
isolated in vitro, mucked about with and then
introduced
into an organism like a fly or a worm, or
a yeast cell or even
a mouse.
This approach has now blown apart much of
biology. We now
understand, for example, much of the molecular
details of how cell
division is controlled, how cells in embryos
take on the correct identity,
how cells and axons migrate to the right destination,
how gender is
determined, how some cells undergo programmed
cell death – the list is
extremely long and I could name examples for
several hours. What is
more, because of the techniques of transgenesis,
it was possible to
introduce DNA from one species into another.
Paul Nurse pioneered this work in the
1980s, showing that the human counterpart
of the yeast cdc2 gene was
able to “rescue” yeast mutants that were
unable to divide properly
because of a defect in their cdc2 gene. In
other words the human genes
and yeast genes were very similar, their function
was said to be
conserved. This was crucially important, because
it meant that, as had
been suspected previously, work on simple
organisms ultimately informs
our knowledge of human biology and disease;
model organisms
became biomedically significant.
Using the genetic approach we have even begun
to understand how lifespan is genetically
programmed and how
behavior may be controlled.
The really revolutionary thing about forward
genetics is its unbiased approach. The
investigator observes a bunch of mutants until
he
or she finds one that displays a defect in
the
process of choice, thus revealing an important
mechanism, and one that can be understood
at
the biochemical level once the sequence of
the
mutant gene is revealed.
The work is unbiased because no assumptions
are made
about the biochemistry of the process under
investigation
– phenotypic analysis leads the geneticist
to the important
genes. A geneticist cannot be fussy about
what kinds of
genes and proteins they want to work on because
the
genetics could lead them anywhere, they are
lead purely
and simply by phenotype.
The work is still going on, of course, but
we have made
massive progress in the last 40 years in using
genetics to
understand how life works, and this extraordinary
effort is
my 5th major revolution in genetics – using
mutants to
understand anything in biology that is genetically
programmed (which is pretty much everything
in biology!).
My 6th and penultimate revolution in genetics
is
genome sequencing and genomics. This work
was
started by Fred Sanger in 1977, who had already
developed a method for
determining the amino acid sequence of proteins
– hence the two Nobel prizes he ended up
with.
Once the technique for sequencing small stretches
of DNA
was worked out, the next thing was to scale
up and sequence
a whole genome, ushering in the field of genomics
– the
study of whole genomes. The bacterium Hemophilus
influenza was the first free-living organism
to be sequenced in
1995, followed by yeast in 1996, the first
multicellular animal,
C. elegans in 1998, the fruit fly in 2000
and human genome,
first draft in 2001 and completion in 2003.
This was an extraordinary
achievement, involving many hundreds of different
workers
from all over the world over a period of around
13 years, and
costing around 2.7 billion dollars. If you
typed the whole
genetic code out (typing at 200 letters per
minute) it would
take 29 years, without taking any breaks!
And yet we’ve got
that inside every single one of our 40 trillion
cells, and our
enzymatic machines can copy it in a matter
of minutes.
“We’ve now got to the point in human history”,
said John Sulston, who spearheaded the project
in the UK, and also worked
tirelessly to ensure that the data remained
in the public domain “Where
for the first time we are going to hold in
our hands the set of
instructions to make a human being”. What
is even more extraordinary
than this, though, is what has happened since.
The technology has
developed so fast that it is now possible
to sequence the human
genome for under a thousand dollars in a matter
of hours.
Thousands of different kinds of organisms
have had their genome
sequenced. The tsunami of data is so huge
that this is, of itself, a huge
problem, in terms of storage alone, let alone
analysis. It was estimated
back in 2013 that biologists around the world
churn out 13 petabases of
sequence a year (1 Pb = 1 million Gigabases,
which is a thousand
megabases). If this were stored on regular
DVDs, the resulting stack
would be 2.2 miles tall! So this 6th revolution
provides challenges, as we
shall see is also the case for the 7th and
last revolution.
It is easy to be dazzled by the possible uses
of
genome information. Sequencing
the genome of your cancer cells may allow
oncologists to tailor-make your treatment
to
increase the chances of success. The speculation
is
that health care professionals will eventually
be
able to use genomic information to predict
what
diseases a person may get in the future and
attempt to minimize the risk, or even eliminate
it
all together through the implementation of
personalized, preventative medicine.
This is not at all straightforward though,
largely because
human disease is rarely caused by mutations
in a single gene
that can be easily traced, such as cystic
fibrosis. Most disease
such as heart disease or cancer, or mental
illness, will result
from an extremely complex interaction of many
different
genes with each other and with the environment.
There is a
public misconception that scientists are discovering
“the
genes for” disease on a daily basis, not
to mention “the genes
for” characteristics, such as binge-drinking
or forgetfulness, or
intelligence, or beauty.
Very little in human biology is straightforwardly
deterministic at the genetic level. Genomics
is better
understood as probabilistic: a whole host
of genetic factors
contribute to the odds, but the outcome is
decided by an
even greater range of genetic, biological
and environmental
influences.
Thus, I do not think we need to take too gloomy
and dystopian a view of medical genomics.
It is
true that there are ethical debates to be
had
around single gene disorders. What about late-
onset disease with no cure? Would you want
to
know? If you do decide to know, then what
about
your family – doesn’t your diagnosis affect
them,
too? Supposing they don’t want to know?
What
are the psychological impacts? Could there
be
genetic discrimination?
But it is simply just not going to be possible
to devise
simple genetic tests for intelligence or
creativity, thank goodness, or even heart
disease,
diabetes, or schizophrenia. It is just too
complicated, and
never let anyone tell you any different. I’m
sure there will
be an explosion in internet companies offering
such tests
in the future. They should probably be banned,
not
because they might give you devastating information,
but
because they will almost certainly give you
misleading
information.
A probabilistic view, on the other hand, might
tell you how
best to avoid your own personal risks. Part
of me thinks,
however, that the advice will boil down to
needing to eat
less fat, drink less alcohol and take more
exercise. Now
where have we heard that before?
I do not want to give you the impression that
genomics poses
no social or ethical challenges: there are
questions of
ownership, privacy and access, and certainly
need for debate.
The debate needs to be had between well-informed
stakeholders who understand the science - not
lobby groups
with a particular agenda.
So that is the 6th revolution in genetics
– the genomic
revolution. The outcome of this revolution
is as yet unclear.
But one thing that is certain is that genome
sequence
information brings all of life closer together
than was ever
thought possible. Literally thousands
of genome sequences are now available, and
comparative
genomics allows us to interrogate evolutionary
relationships
between different species with more resolution
than ever
before.
DNA is not just an instruction manual for
the
making of an organism – a human, a bat or
a
mouse – it is also a history book, a historical
record of all the genetic mutations that have
happened, by chance, to make us what we are,
and to make everything else what it is. We
are all
related through an unbroken chain of many
billions of copyings through 4 billion years.
Imagine how excited Darwin and Mendel would
have been if they had known all this.
My final revolution in genetics, the 7th revolution,
also takes us into the
future, but this revolution, unlike the genomics
revolution, has only just
begun. It is genome editing using what is
called the CRISPR-Cas9
system. Geneticists have developed several
techniques for genome
editing – ie changing the genetic makeup
of organisms by causing
targeted change in the nucleotide sequence
- in the past. But the revolutionary thing
about CRISPR-Cas9 is that it works
with extremely high efficiency and is very
versatile.
So what on earth is it? The technique makes
use of the natural immune
defences of bacteria, which have come up with
“molecular scissors” to
remove unwanted DNA, for example DNA transferred
by an infecting
virus. These molecular scissors, or nucleases
– the Cas9 - can cut out
sections of DNA with extreme precision. They
are guided to cut the
precise bit of DNA to be modified by a synthetically
made guide RNA
that directs the cut through hybridization
with its matching genomic
sequence. When the cell repairs the break,
errors can occur to generate
a knockout of that gene or additional modifications
can be introduced.
This technology therefore has the potential
to re-write the
genetic code. Genetic conditions could therefore
be treated
by modifying the DNA of affected cells, like
rubbing out so
many typos.
There is the possibility of radical new therapies
for a range of
diseases. Although single gene disorders are
rare, if you add
them up they affect an awful lot of people,
so collectively
they are not rare. Genetic Alliance UK estimates
that 5.5% of
the UK population suffer from one of 6000
Mendelian
(caused by a mutation in just one gene) diseases
by age 25 –
that is 3.5 million people. So the impact
of genome editing in
these patients and their families could be
enormous.
Human embryos could also be modified, such
that the disease-causing
mutation is over-ridden, not just in that
individual,
but in their children, their children’s
children, and
so on. Is this a good plan? Research institutions,
funders and scientists have called for a renewed
debate on the ethics of modifying human embryos,
before the science gets ahead of public opinion.
The overwhelming view of scientists at present
is
that the procedure is too new to know how
safe it
is. One big concern is that a public backlash
could
impact on the race to develop new and safe
therapies.
So do we go out to bravely meet this vision,
as Thucydides
would have said, glory and danger alike? Is
this playing God?
Is editing the human germline a “line that
should never be
crossed”? Is it the first step on the road
to designer babies?
Whatever we may think about the answer to
this question,
one thing is resoundingly clear. Talking about
it is essential,
like for genomic-based diagnosis. Public debate
must be at a
high level, with all parties understanding
the science, such
that rhetoric doesn’t get to replace fact.
Public trust in science depends on openness,
transparency
and effective regulation, and this is the
approach that must
be taken. There is no scientific answer to
what is the “right”
response to the potential use of technology.
That answer has
to be provided by society
The amazing thing for me about the CRISPR-
Cas9 system is that once again, evolution
shows
us the way. Evolution has come up with these
remarkable enzymes and we have the privilege
of being intelligent enough to make use of
them. So this brings me full circle, from
Darwin
and his lack of a theory of heredity, through
Mendel, Morgan, the DNA folk, to genomics
and
genome editing.
This has been a whistle-stop tour and I have
left
out countless important revolutions on the
way, including
Barbara McClintock’s work on jumping genes,
or transposable
elements, showing that genomes are not static
at all but
highly dynamic, technological revolutions
such as PCR and
gene cloning, that paved the way for the revolution
in
genome editing, newish ideas about epigenetics
and
revolutions in the RNA world…in fact Genetics
is so exciting
and revolutionary that it is hardly possible
to say anything at
all in an hour.
If I were to sum up what I’ve said in one
sentence, it would be
to note the extraordinary counterpoint in
biology between
astonishing variety on the one hand, yet astonishing
constancy in fundamental mechanisms on the
other.
I’m sure that you will agree with me that
the revolutions
are, if anything, gaining in momentum, so
we are in for
exciting times...
If you were to ask JBS Haldane about the
future of biology he would say the following:
“In forecasting
the future of scientific research there is
one quite general law
to be noted. The unexpected always happens.
So one can be
quite sure that the future will make any detailed
predictions
look silly. Yet an actual research worker
can perhaps see a
little further than the intelligent onlooker.
Even so, it may
seem presumptious for any one man, especially
one who is
almost completely ignorant of botany, to attempt
to cover,
however inadequately, the whole field of biological
investigation.”
I hope you will forgive me my terrible oversights
if I end with another quote from Haldane:
“My
own suspicion is that the universe is not
only
queerer than we suppose, but queerer than
we
CAN suppose”.
Thank you!